for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
okay so as i mentioned in the previous
video there are some anomalous
configurations some weird exceptions to
the Aufbau principle and two of them
here are chromium and copper how exactly
are the exceptions well let's see what
we get from the expected configuration
using the Alpha principle and they kind
of see what the actual configuration
isn't how it relates so the condensed
ground state configuration for chromium
would be everything up until argon which
is 18 electrons and then there's going
to be 4 s 2 and then 3 D 4 for a total
of 24 electrons so the orbital diagram
for that would look like this or s 2 and
3 d 4 so 1 2 3 4 what's the actual
configuration the actual configuration
is 4 s 1 3 D 5 which looks like this 1 2
3 4 5 what's going on here well this
actual configuration we've got all of
the 3 D orbitals half filled with
electrons we don't have this one that's
totally empty so basically the electron
that was in the 4s orbital kind of
dropped down to the 3 D orbital ok so
basically what's going on here is that
having all of these 3 D orbitals half
filled and this one 4s orbital also half
filled is more stable than having the 4s
orbital filled and the 3 D orbital kind
of left hanging with that empty one
there
so the idea simply is that having them
all half filled is more stable in this
case
more stable okay so that's what's going
on there this situation is more stable
than this so this is an exception to the
Aufbau principle as expected
configuration copper similar idea
actually got 29 electrons so everything
up until argon it's 18 so two more would
be twenty plus nine more be three-day
night so we'd have 4 s 2 + 3 D 9 would
be 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 I think you might
imagine what happens here this this
orbital here it's only half filled while
via the rest are filled so it's gonna
happen here is that we get 4 s 1 + 3 D
10 so this for us is 1 then we have 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so here having the 3 D
completely filled as opposed to having
the 4s filled in the 3d nearly entirely
filled is more stable so this situation
here is more stable then then this so
again an exception to what we would
expect from using the alpha alpha pal
principles okay so I want you to
definitely keep chromium and copper in
mind for sure but also keep in mind
there there are others okay just be
aware of this concept it's free ever
asked about questions relating to
electron configuration especially when
thinking about the transition metals
also consider the the other elements
that are are in the same group as
chromium and copper like molybdenum and
and and silver keep in mind what might
happen with those or what in fact does
happen with those anyway I hope this
video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying